you're sort of interested in performing
on Dancing with the Stars is that
something you would really do I mean I
mean it's fun they called me a lot to do
it and I just you know I just don't
think I could do it because of the
conformity you have to do you know the
conformity of the dance they made you
yeah technically you have to did you
have to do what they do you know like
that's meaning if they had like a
freestyle I would you get to do whatever
you guys Oh kill it kill it I mean the
thing is is though like like certain
dances make you dance like you do with
salsa music you would have to dance like
if you ever heard salsa music you can't
not not dance going okay you're not a
big dancer are you
I wouldn't say and people don't like it
when I dance I dance if you put salsa
music going just go ahead guys I'm just
going to see see the thing what happens
coding if you spin it around
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what you far I didn't practice I didn't
know warm up first reformed is in
theaters right now subject the
Entertainer
[Applause]
you